my name is uh
jason gilman and today i'm going to talk
to you about
visualization driven development so a
little about me first
i'm a software engineer i work for
element 84 which is a small company in
alexandria virginia
and for the last eight years i've been
working on a nasa earth science search
application
that's a long time to work on a single
project but i've been able to follow it
through
multiple refactorings and rewriting and
different languages starting out in java
and going to ruby and then now looking
at closure so i wanted to start off with
a question
are we at the pinnacle of computing and
by this i mean
is software development like the way
that we do it is it going to get better
or is it
we figured it out we've got it all
solved now
i freely admit this is a straw man of
course not it's going to get better
but it's a good a good place to start
because if we know it can get better
we can ask the question like well how
how could it be better
one way that i'd like to see it get
better is with communication
and what i mean is not between like a
developer and a user i mean between your
brain as a developer
and what's going on inside the computer
so typically software development goes
like this
we write some code we execute it we get
some output
and sometimes the app is what we expect
and sometimes it's you know something
completely off
so we want to know what's happening here
in this middle part
what's going on i mean obviously you
know we're
we're smart we think we know what we're
doing we have a mental model in our head
of what's going to happen in the
computer
but it doesn't often reflect that so we
have a tool belt like a set of tools
that we go into use
so we got the logging debugger reple
these all these are nice i mean they
have their advantages but they also have
their disadvantages
and one of the nice things about logging
is that it's so easy it's so easy to put
like a log message in there and it just
shows up but logs are just essentially
just this vomiting of information
there's no context
there's no organization but the debugger
is nice
with a debugger we can you know pause
the world and see what's going on right
now
we can see you know what the current
state is but we can't tell what's going
on in other threads
and if we you know hit a break point
what happened before it hit that
breakpoint we can tell what the state is
right now
but we can't tell what before we got
there or have you ever put a break point
in the middle of a loop over a thousand
items
what are you gonna hit play a thousand
times
but so a lot of people are you know
using the rupple more often now
to help solve some of these and i think
the rebel the rebel is great
like you know i'm i'm into closure i
like the rebel
yay but it's it's kind of request
response
you know you write some code or you call
a function in it and you get some
results back
now if you call a function you can't see
what
what does the function actually do to
achieve that
and so you know we're building up these
complicated applications
you know there's many requests coming in
at the same time many different users
there's big reams of state that we have
to deal with
and i think our tools are failing us a
little bit
they do work but we need something
better
and so part of the reason that they are
you know failing us is because they're
all textual i think this next question
kind of illustrates it a little bit
so you can look at this and in order for
your brain to figure out
the answer to it you have to decipher
these letters you have to recognize
m m is an acronym it means millimeters
it's a unit of length and there's m is
meters and so you do this conversion
either you go look it up online or you
just remember there's a style
a thousand millimeters in a meter but if
i ask the same question and i show you a
picture of a basketball and a baseball
it's it's dead simple there's still work
that goes on there
you know but it's a tiny amount of work
so if i take our original question
and i show it on a graph it's much
easier to see now you can
you can compare them you can visually
see what's going on
and so i've taken the original question
and i've turned it into
the baseball basketball problem
so when you go back to our log files you
look at them and you think
in that and what your brain had to do to
interpret 550 millimeters
you have to now do this across gigabytes
and gigabytes of text
that does not scale as an approach to
understanding things
like when i signed up to be a you know a
programmer i did not want to get really
good at parsing text with my eyes
and so i want to think at a higher level
but in the real world people don't use
text for everything
they have concrete examples that help
them understand you know and make
decisions
so let's say see an example you're going
to plan a wedding
and so as part of planning a wedding
there's a lot of decisions you have to
make
maybe you hire a wedding planner and so
they're going to ask you things like
what kind of music do you want
and so what if they show you this say
what do you think about this
i'm not a i'm not a trained musician and
but even if i was i think i'd really
just like to hear it
i think i could make a much faster
decision
based on that what if they ask you what
about the cake for the reception
is this a good cake it might be a little
small i mean but i can read it here
others you know there's sugar we have
flour eggs chocolate
it sounds like a cake and it sounds
tasty
but really i'd like to taste it or maybe
see a picture of it
i don't end up with something like this
and so i can tell like immediately yes
halloween party no
wedding um so that brings us back to
this mystery in the middle problem
so we want to know what's going on here
so i think
data visualization is the answer that's
staring us in the face
we've been using visualizations for
centuries
and we've been using visualizations in
our applications
ever since we started computing but as
software developers we hardly ever
reach for this as a tool now we do build
them into production level applications
you know to show a you know a dashboard
or something
or maybe we will use pretty printing at
the repple that's a form of
visualization
but we don't really go beyond that very
often and so i think we need
data visualization that's the answer but
so how do we combine that with code that
might not be clear
and so one thing we know from homo
iconic languages like closure
is that code is data code code can be
represented as data this is some closure
code at the bottom
and now it's not only is it code but
it's just a list as well
and so not only can code be data but
code execution can be data
so what i mean by that we take data we
call a function we get back more data
what's going on in that function if we
want to know we just take a look inside
it's just more data it's data being
split up merged
manipulated transformed going through
various versions
and we can capture that motion of the
data what's happening there
well then we have a picture a picture in
data of what your code is doing
and so now that we have data we have
that's actually something we can
visualize
so let's see an example so this is quick
sort
implementing closure this is something i
found online
and um if you're not familiar with
quicksort basically we're going to sort
a list of numbers we're going to grab
the first one and call that our pivot
we're going to go through the rest of
the list and find everything less than
that move that to the beginning
everything bigger than that gets moved
to the end and then it iterates down and
recurses
this is recur this is a recursive
implementation and so it goes down to
the sides
so we're going to capture and visualize
what is quicksort doing we kind of need
to capture those three things the pivot
the left and the right sides and the
fact that it's iterating
and so if we just maybe put a call in
the middle
capture we'll have a map now
and when we run quick sort we'll capture
all that data
and so now now we've got some data a
data picture of what quicksort looks
like
if we take that original unsorted data
this capture data and the final sorted
results
well then we can throw it into a
visualization maybe something like this
quick sorts where
we're dealing with lists of numbers so a
bar chart might work and we would show
each iteration as like a separate image
on top of that so this is the original
list
and we could see okay what does
quicksort do in the first iteration
well it grabs a pivot we'll show that
with a separate color and the other
things that it's operating on in green
and you can see it move the things there
so you can tell like right away okay
quick start starts the whole list
then the next iteration it recurses down
you can see
you can see as well like quick sort how
fast it is is the second iteration
the list is mostly sorted at this point
so this idea of making something that's
abstract tangible making computing
tangible
through visualizations is not a new one
i did not wake up this morning and go
aha i know what i'm going to talk about
today
you might have seen it before at the
logo programming language you might have
seen this in grade school
this is a language devoted to drawing
and the way that you accomplish your
drawing is you give instructions to a
turtle and it walks around the screen
and leaves a line behind it
it was invented in 1967 by a
mathematician at mit
named seymour papert and he wrote this
great book called mindstorms about it
now originally the the turtle was
actually a robot add a pen in the bottom
and you could set it down on a piece of
paper and when your program ran it would
move around
and then you would get at the end a
physical manifestation of your program
running
you know a piece of paper and it's
almost like a printer
and so papert hoped that logo would be a
way for
children to learn about math and it was
it's a powerful concept they're going to
take something that
might seem abstract distant
and make it tangible like something that
you can understand
this is not just for kids like i do not
walk out of
you know college with my degree and i'm
perfect programmer now i know everything
i need to know
now as we go along we are continually
learning we are continually learning
how does my code work when i run it what
happens
you know we're continually learning
every day so typically when you're
programming a logo
you follow the series of steps so this
is straight out of the mindstorms book
a teacher asks a student a question and
says how can we get the turtle to draw a
house
and so up until then they had learned
functions like how to
tell the turtle draw a triangle and a
square the student thought
we'll just combine those two together
and we'll have a house
oh no not a house uh it's an envelope
okay well then they would think okay
what do we need to do to actually make
that
look like what we want we could rotate
the triangle
outside of the square maybe rotate the
whole thing and then success
this should look familiar because this
is what we do every day we're not
drawing houses
but we are coming up with a plan we're
writing some code that invariably has
problems in it and then we're iterating
on that
to get to success
but the difference here is that as
you're going you can see what's
happening
you can see is this what i want you have
a mental model in your head you have
this concrete idea
of these things moving around in your
program wouldn't it be nice if you could
just see that
and know am i getting closer to what i
want or is it farther away
and know exactly when you get there and
this is the process that i wanted to
bring to
modern day software development this is
what i call visualization driven
development
and so this is what we're going to do
thermody software we're not going to
write logo we're going to write in
something like ruby or closure
but we'll be able to see what's
happening and so i've been doing this
over the past year
and i've done it a bunch in ruby and
then more recently enclosure
and so i've kind of captured some of the
hard problems
some of them anyway in a library that i
call vdd core
and so this is written in closure and
closure script and it's targeting
closure right now
so if you're not programming enclosure
don't head out the door
like all of the ideas and the techniques
and
the concepts behind it are relatable to
you they work in any programming
language
the specific library yes is focused on
closure but these
concepts do not so one thing i've known
from
the visualizations that i've built is
that targeting the web browser makes a
lot of sense there is a lot of
frameworks out there like d3 and raphael
and just great web browser technologies
like svg and canvas
it just makes sense to piggyback on top
of the work there so vdd core targets
visualizing your code in a web browser
so the way that it works is this
you're going to have a coding
environment you have some code there and
so your coding environment that's your
editor that's your reply that's where
you
typically run things so what we want to
visualize things in the browser and what
vddcore provides is a
built-in embedded server and it's going
to use web sockets to push that data
over to the browser the reason we use
web sockets is because
we want to be able to run our code just
like we're used to in the rupple
normally
but push over data whenever we want and
have it show up in the browser
and we also want to be able to have
interactive applications and allow our
applications to say
what happens if i do this and have that
request make
execution make our code execute and have
more data to visualize and so websockets
allow that two-way traffic
and then in the browser we also have
some visualization utilities and the
client code for dealing with that
but all of this is to get that code
execution data over into
your visualization so that is not the
the one thing that i am not providing is
a
one one visualization that's gonna work
for everybody and i've just found that
when you're writing some code there and
there's gonna be different domain
concepts that you want to communicate
and so there's not one visualization
that's going to show that
just like there's not one data
visualization for all data
so we're trying to make make that easier
though
so i'll talk to you a little bit about
how we use it
so that quicksort code i showed earlier
that capture call that's part of vdd
core that's provided
and that just saves it in a in an atom
and then we're going to go into our repl
we'll start the visualization server
and once you do that you can hit it vde
core in the browser
and when you do that you're going to see
a list of visualizations these are the
ones
for your specific project these are not
throwaway things we're going to build
one for a specific component or
specific application and they're going
to stay around they're going to go into
our git repository and so you define
them
in the viz folder and when vdd course
starts up it looks through that folder
and finds them and you have them
available
to use and so if we're going to run this
from the repl
one thing that i typically do is i build
a driver so what the driver does is it
handles
capturing that state uh munging it a
little bit so that it's easier to
visualize and then sending it to
the browser and so the quick sort driver
here
what it's doing is it first calls reset
captured it might be a little small but
it's
not really important so it calls reset
captured clear out any previously
captured state
we're going to call quick sort it's
going to force the side effect of that
data being captured
and then we're going to grab the
captured data and now if you think about
quicksort the way i described it earlier
it's recursing down into subsections of
the list
and we want to be able to visualize not
just those sub sections but the whole
list
so we want to kind of combine that back
together and that's what cue sort list
combiner does
and then we prepend the unsorted data
append the sorted data
and then we're going to send that to the
visualization the last call here data
arrowviz
sends it over and it gets sent over as
json through the websockets
and when it shows up it looks kind of
like this so we and this is specific to
quicksort but at the top here we have
a bar chart in d3 and
this is basically the first example you
learned when you learn d3 is here let's
build a bar chart
and then at the bottom you'll notice
there's some buttons some play pause and
a slider
this is a pre-built component as part of
bdd core
so and what its job is to do is to take
a series of data
that's been captured over time and turn
it back into
data over time again and so it's going
to take your data when you click play
it's going to iterate through that
series
and basically call a visualization
function the function that you're
writing to visualize your code
and then you'll end up with an animation
as it pauses between calls
and so d3 if you're using that will
handle transitioning
so let's see what that looks like so
this is uh quick sorting
50 numbers we can click play you can
start to see it animated so you can see
right away quicksort goes to the
beginning of the list and it works its
way to the end
and when the player component gets to
the end it loops around to the beginning
again
but we can pause execution at any time
it's not pausing execution it's pausing
playback
and we can step backwards in time or
step forward in time
then we can we can basically jump
anywhere and see what's happening or
what happened when we ran our code this
is a
this is an image of the past in a way
so maybe thinking like okay that's great
like i can visualize quick sort but
quick sort is easy we have a list of
numbers like obviously we can put that
into
one of the things we learned in high
school like a bar chart and display it
but that might be it might not be clear
how do we visualize your code
and so what i've done is i've kind of
thought of the steps that you would take
to design a visualization for code
execution
and so the steps are basically we're
going to identify the nouns what are the
entities in your code if you're writing
like ruby object-oriented you know code
this would be like the names of your
classes if you're in closure
it would be the names of the entities
that you give to the functions to the
data that flows through your functions
so for each one of those nouns we pull
out we're then going to choose
a visual representation for it so these
you picked out the things you want to
see now you
think each piece how do i want to
visualize that
and then now we have a two-dimensional
area of the browser we have to lay that
out
so you choose a layout so it's basically
just these three steps here you can come
up with a
way to visualize it and so what i'm
going to do is walk through a real world
problem that i had
in my job and i had built a
visualization for it and i'm going to
use these steps to design it
so the i work on a nasa earth science
search application i said before
and so we have a bunch of our science
data and so people want to find that
data and that we have a rest api
and so they can say something like
they're looking for earth science data
near this particular point
it's going to have less than 32 cloud
clever cloud cover
and they're looking for precipitation
data
and internally this gets mapped into a
query model
and so we have a set of conditions
they're handed together but our data is
not all publicly visible
so we have to somehow limit what you're
seeing
to what providers the providers of the
data say you have access to
so we take all of those data rules and
we basically turn them into query
conditions and and them together
so now we have a bigger tree and it's
much bigger
because there are a lot of data rules
and so this executes very slowly
we want it to be fast so we need is an
equivalent query
that does basically it's going to find
the same data but it's smaller
and so we can do that using boolean
algebra simplification
along with some domain knowledge so if i
know you're looking for precipitation
data
and provider food does not offer
precipitation data well that can just be
removed from the query
and so these combined approaches to
simplify it will make it smaller
but we want this process to be correct
like we cannot find the wrong data and
we cannot
let you have access to data that you
don't have permission to view
so this is a great candidate for
visualization and so how are we going to
build a visualization for it so
first step identify the nouns so these
are might
be what you pull out conditions
operations
uh the query itself and then after we've
identified some of these we choose a
visual representation for them
so one type of advice is like keep it
simple so start off with a simple
approach first so for conditions textual
it can be good enough here now you might
be thinking like well i said text was
bad earlier well that's not
text isn't bad text is great in a way
but these pieces that we're building
will be combined together in a visual
way
we still want the text there just like
in a bar chart we still want text at the
bottom otherwise
just bars of a certain height tells us
nothing
and the operations we can use text as
well or we can visually
make it visually distinct by using
something like a svg circle
with ampersands the query is really not
an entity in and of itself it's really a
combination of these other entities
in a tree and so we could just lay those
other elements out
in a tree and then we'll have something
we can view and so that actually answers
the next question which is how are we
going to lay it out and so now that we
know
how we want to lay it out there's two
different implementations we could use
there's actually a lot of
implementations but two i'm going to
cover
one we could use d3 so d3 has a built-in
tree layout
we use that we get something that looks
like this typical tree shape
but we could also use html unordered
lists so if you nest
html under lists you essentially get an
outline view and an outline is
essentially a tree
and so this could be a simpler way to do
it
but it may not communicate as well as
the d3 so you have to
weigh the two so then you would go and
implement it
these examples that i'm going through
are all online vdd core examples
including the quick sort one
and so when you implement it you'll have
to annotate your code to capture the
execution
you're going to then under the viz
folder because that's the one vdd core
is scanning
you're going to create a folder for that
visualization along with the driver
the html file the css and the javascript
and then i've done that for the the d3
method and so for the presentation i
implemented one simplification
and that is the collapsing of ands so if
you know if you have
a parent and and child ands with
subconditions under them
that those child conditions of these sub
ands can actually be moved up into the
parent
so this flattening of the tree allows
more
you know domain specific simplifications
to occur
so i've ran it now uh this there's
actually the player component i just
don't have it captured in the
visualization but i could click
play and then it would start showing you
what happens
what's nice about this is it's not a a
series of static images that it actually
shows you
where they were previously and then
where they are now you can actually see
them move
and all i had to do here was i captured
the original
way the tree looked in code and then in
my code i captured
where does it where did each node move
as it gets simplified and then to tell
d3 i just basically did the same thing
what does the original tree look like
and then when the player component's
running all it's doing is saying this
node's here now
d3 do your things and d3 does all of the
animation for me i don't have to do that
so when you start using visualizations
like this it makes it easy to spot
problems so when i first did this for
the presentation i actually had a bug in
my code
if i run the animation you can see what
happens
so it stops it says i'm done but it's
not done there's the
more at the bottom so if you look at it
you can start to
guess why it might be failing so it
might have something to do with the
depth of the tree
there's a you know there's it's deeper
down there and then there's
something connecting the two of them the
or the or clause
and so actually if i go look at my code
i found oh i wasn't recursing into
the or clause in my and simplification
that's an easy mistake to make
and so i can just fix that in code and
then when i run it again
everything gets simplified
so this kind of shows when you start
using visualizations it makes it really
easy to spot
problems and when you see a problem
there's a lot of information
you can derive that tells you where the
problem's coming from or what you have
to do to fix it
and you can tell when you fixed it
everything here becomes plainly obvious
so you still might be skeptical like
this
like what i'm proposing is not
visualizations on a silver platter
it is not here plug this library in and
you get it for free
now you have to design a visualization
you have to annotate your code to
capture this execution data
and then you now have to actually
implement the visualization
so it sounds like it could be a lot of
work and it could be
so i have some advice on how do you
avoid
doing unnecessary work and how do you
make sure that any work that you
do is worth it we have to remember that
our job is not building visualizations
at least my job isn't my job is writing
code that works
and so we should only adopt something if
it's really going to help us get our job
done
i believe that visualizations do help
with that and so one way that we can
avoid some of the extra work is to keep
it simple so i mentioned
html ordered lists that's a simpler way
to do it that might be easier than d3
because it's another framework you have
to learn
that it pays off it's not as nice as d3
the way the tree looks isn't as nice but
it may communicate just as efficiently
and we can hook it up to the player
component that i showed before so we can
play that and actually
see it get simplified down
and this is actually what i did when i
implemented it for real so this is an
image of the actual visualization i
built
and down the left hand side i have the
life cycle the request
don't worry about trying to read this
it's way too small even for me up here
to read
and then you would have the before and
after query state so we had this
serious performance issue and we were
trying to figure it out it was really
hard
to understand why the queries were slow
when
when they were fast why were they fast
and so i spent a day and a half
building this visualization and then
once i had it it became
pretty clear what was going on like the
data access rules there were so many of
them that was creating
giant queries and there was assumptions
we made about the size of queries
that we were expecting and so i found
pure ruby code dealing with
objects no i o at all that was taking
seconds to just
manipulate these trees and so i was able
to fix problems like that
and see all sorts of other
simplifications that we could make
in order to like make this tree more
compact
another thing you should be doing is
building reusable visualizations
when you find a visualization that is
useful on many components of your
application or across
multiple applications building that
putting the time in and the effort and
to do it
is going to pay off over and over again
there's a tool that almost everyone here
i uses that's a visual tool at least if
you do web development
and that's the web developer tools that
are built right into our web browser
so yes it has a javascript debugger and
a console the typical things
but it also has great visualizations
like the one at the bottom this
network view it shows you all the
requests that have come in how long
they've taken
and you have a timeline view you can see
what the latencies were and
the size of the request and so it makes
it easy to debug
performance problems with your web apps
so why if we have great tools like this
do we just put up with logs on the
server side
this is a tool this is a mock-up of a
tool that i wish existed
and so it's basically like the web
developer tools but for the server side
and the way i envision it down the left
hand side you would get
what requests came into the server what
was the path to it how long did each
request take
and you could see details when you
clicked on it in the middle like the
http headers the response headers the
body
and then what code was actually
associated with that
that fulfilled that request how long did
they take and be able to select one of
them and see
what was actually passed in there now
this might not seem
like a visual tool but it is it's a
visual organization of information
and this is we put way more in here you
can see way more than you would ever
want to put in a log file
a log file would be unreadable to get
all of this out
but because this is an actual
application we can visually organize
things
by you know there's a context here i
know the left side is requests
and i can hide away details until
they're needed and pull them up on
demand i think developing software
is a little bit like woodworking and
carpentry so as a woodworker you need to
be really careful
about what you're doing and make sure
things you are making are correct like
what we do
and so things you make like the chair
legs here
have to be the exact same size and so
you can use simple tools
and measure you know the legs and mark
them off and cut them
and make sure they're the right size and
if they're still off you can sand it
down
but that process of using these simple
tools and that approach doesn't scale
and so similarly the approach that we're
using often doesn't scale as well
we do not write a bunch of code and then
have to fix one bug and we're done
and we keep going back to the same code
over and over again to add features
and fix things and split it apart and
refactor
but woodworkers have a tool that they
they build that helps them with this and
it's called a jig
so the jig in this picture is this
triangle piece of wood here
it's just a couple pieces they scrap
what they put together
and so they can cut this other piece of
trim here and they cut they built the
jig
carefully to make sure that it's the
right size but now they can just throw
these pieces of wood up against the side
and cut it and it's going to be right so
jig is kind of a magical thing
you build it yourself and it makes your
work easier
you can just throw those pieces of wood
up against the side and cut it in the
right and it gives you higher quality
results
you can cut 10 pieces of wood in a row
they're all going to be exactly the same
i guarantee you that's better than if
you took a protractor out and a straight
edge in a marker and then cut it
yourself
visualizations are the same thing
we the way that i'm describing them we
build them ourselves
they make our work easier it's so much
easier to spot these problems
we know how to fix them after we see
them and they give us higher quality
results because
we see problems that we didn't even see
were there before
and we can see ways to make things
faster that we didn't even know about
thank you
[Applause]